hello nice to meet you too Thank You
Arnold what was your reaction the first
time you heard Linda say aback the first
time I saw it was on a screen so I was
not the Avenger shot that scene so I
knew that it was in the script and I
knew that she's gonna say it but I was
curious oh how is she gonna say it and I
thought it was really great and to kind
of pass that line on there because I've
said it a million times in the movies
and off-screen yeah who pumps more iron
between the two of you do you think
you're very kind to say nothing
definitely Arnold wins that one if you
could go back to 1984 and give advice to
yourself what would you say pretty much
I would say to myself never go on film
in 1984 because you've got really really
bad hair and it has lived on and on and
on yeah give her like did you ever
expect to come back and I'm like with
that hair are you really pretty awful
time in in the world for hair I can't
even face so you know I cannot really
come up with anything because I think
that in 1984 the way we did the movie
was great the way my career went after
that went really well
so I cannot really say here's one thing
that I could have done better
yes I have chosen certain movie
sometimes that didn't do that well in
some movies it went through the roof but
you know there's no science behind it
you never really know what clicks and
what doesn't with the audience but I I'm
very satisfied with my career yeah I
heard on set you like to quote yourself
sometimes you make jokes you play chess
what's it like when you're not shooting
with Arnold
well we have different lives offset I
mean we joke around and hang around and
I hugged him a lot couldn't help myself
just so happy to be back together but he
goes and does his thing and I read books
it's a one-word answer I read books like
that's a three word answer it's a one
sentence answer yeah I I also discovered
that for a woman of my age to be doing
all of that action lifting those weights
and training so hard that really rest is
so much more important you can't build
muscle until you rest and so rest is
more important than ever and so I would
just lie down and rest my body and then
take my mind elsewhere so I read 40
books on this film oh my god yeah I mean
I'm an avid reader you're in the book
club oh by myself awesome well thank you
guys absolutely thank you